maxime on sait pour bien occuper de vous
dans 7 à vous avez été piégé deux fois
deux fois mon maxime il pensé se rendre
à un speed dating pour la quotidienne à
son arrivée on a prétexté un problème
technique l'annonçant qu'on n'avait plus
le retour image et en cas de problème il
devait dire poulets rôtis très
importante ou 06 vous allez voir et
l'équipe de production intervient
directement
regardez comment un moment de séduction
peut mal tourner avec machines des nues
c'est du très très très très lourd
c'est dans la grande race sera 3
regardez c'est parti
[Musique]
au mas excusez moi tout le monde on va
commencer à tout s'est passé comment
savoir le site nous venons certaines
sociétés mais mon pseudo pour ce soir
exceptionnellement savall d'accord mars
à manas vas-y parement poteau je suis
journaliste a senti quelque chose
justement des chansons
non non tu me trouves beau gosse je vais
très très beau et très bientôt
première question
ok t'es maxime c'est moi je me pose
malaga serait donc c'est vrai de
changement de mentalité
voilà et quand je vais dire en jeep anti
jeu
les rebelles qui font le mec je te jure
c'est mon préféré
non voilà c'est pour s'acheter une
direction du ttp choc c'était comment ça
ouais ça veut dire je me trouve le héros
de la victoire contre un marché dans ce
match des particules volatiles achète ce
serait sa priorité
rater derrière
tours
mûri
[Musique]
regardez
de cayola jettons le jeter en fait je
fais de la déconcentration
en vaut-elle dakar fait je rentre
travailler les jeux ou des éléments à
chaque fois que cet os inverse des
[Musique]
écoutes max et moi je t'ai dit que
c'était
je prépare les jeunes zara
c'est fini avec lui je le tuerais de
parler stable
ça donne mal j'ai rencontré mon cher et
qu'ils ont à l'époque
balou choisissant si on fait ça je t'en
supplie qu'on se connaît pas mais
seulement d'une chose si vous installez
jours
[Applaudissements]
oui mais j'ai besoin d'un bon poulet
rôti ça se passe bien mais sauf que la
fille complètement folle tour 4 c'est
vraiment mais qui m'a demandé ce qui
sera sa place
ce n'est pas tout ça
il fait même chose avec parcimonie et
puis on prendra des mois entiers et ceci
est faux aussi dans leur jeu fait quoi
si tu fais quoi mais comment ça je fais
pas ici ceux qui sont clos ces personnes
quand sa situation se fût moins calmes
en ce qui ce mec c'est là c'est la folie
est à cala montjoi montant le ton est
assez écoutés je suis c'est bon ce temps
de fonctionnement quand ces messieurs
[Applaudissements]
chez les messieurs c'est une réunion
pour rencontrer des amis de l'autre
glisse et à notre organisation pour
trouver des airs de son époux
ce jour écrit à ma femme de péter la
gueule
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bien sûr
[Applaudissements]
toi papa vous attendez un peu des deux
attends je suis pas bien dans ta porte
le maire toujours coquette elle ne
s'attaque pas le droit mais tu me parles
matthaus aventure remplie toi je te jure
je te plains devrait découvrir dans le
rouge avant dernier du vote reyel est
actuellement blessé ok gens voteront
pour les formes et je peux me coûte
autour tout à fait comme ça ok tu as
besoin de te balma même ça c'est pas
quitte à faire
vous allez pas moi
tu continues comme ça tu revanche la mer
ok tu t'en vas pas
je vois tu vas voir la ville et
pertinents on va tous mourir
tranquillement bancaire
il faut savoir tout
logements plus petits d'accord
selon 58 humains dans le sang
[Musique]
vim
[Applaudissements]
battu battu battu battu
un maxime agathe à moi je me sentais en
sécurité maximum plus petits moi je
propose qu'on voit tout de suite
il ya là mais moi il ya deux meilleures
phrases toutefois plus petits bien
entendu il ya c'est la folie sera
enterré au mauvais rôle à ceux qui se
moquent aux cétacés
comment ça c'est une tension sous-marine
bon c'est qui ce mec c'est la salle
absolue au touche pas aux plus petits on
va le revoir et françois mokhtar et vous
avez craqué l'art et la science est là
elle l'a fait par la fille elle commence
à pleurer alors les doigts public un
média qui est formidable merci médina et
la regarder
il n'a très beau dos très beau délire
vous étiez alors espinas je la verrais
bien et vous franchement aussi elle
synthétise et d'ailleurs ont fait un
très beau court tous les deux devraient
très honnête parfait c'est une belle
comédienne elle sait les contacts et les
célibataires salvateur non merci
mais il ya une heure il proposait sa
belle de nuit dans médée sur tous les
dossiers
c'est un truc de fou et maxime je suis
fier de vous ouais bon chemin
[Applaudissements]